5,000 a month, bro. Get the out of here, Nick. Oh my god. Are
you serious, dude?
No shot. No
shot. On this planet Earth does he say that the amount of money
he makes a month is $5,000.
That's crazy.
That's out of this world.
That's embarrassing for him to try to
All right, we move on to the NMP stuff. I think so. So, if you
guys if you guys saw maybe this was a couple days ago,
who did we have? We had Do I not have this girl's thing? Yeah,
this girl. This girl a clip came out from her about a week ago.
>> This is like Julia Kins, right? So, she leaked some
stuff about NMP's lawsuit cuz she was supposed to hang out with
them. And then
I think she basically says like it's over meal prep, but we uh
ended up getting a last minute call. I might tell the story a
little bit later when all of our friends join us, but uh I got
the okay to mention on my stream. Uh but uh congratulations.
W's in the chat for Nick because the court uh the court session,
trial, whatever you want to call it, is officially
over. IT IS OFFICIALLY OVER. WELL, NOT OFFICIALLY. I guess you
can say kind of not. Uh we're still waiting on a uh
>> is she pro or antimp? Well, I think she was prompt just
cuz she was about to hang out with him,
right? So, she must have been she was about to do like a an actual
collab with a guy. I assume she's friends with NMP >> on
a definite um resolution, I guess you could say. >> She
just she just said that Nick gave her per permission to say this
publicly. >> Say, but for the most part in terms of going
back and forth with the lawyers and all of that kind of good
stuff, it is officially case closed.
Um I will be uh we can talk about it later when Dean and Arthur
join. So, basically, we ended up uh after Arthur's stream yesterday,
we ended up um going to the trial and we were there to support
Nick and and things like that. So, um divorce stuff is finally
uh coming to a close. Uh we are just waiting on uh the judge's
uh I guess final verdict, I suppose. I'm sorry if I'm using all
the wrong jargon. I'm not really um I'm not really >> Okay,
so this came out about a week ago. This is the first inkling
we had that this was going to be basically finished. All right.
About a week ago, we had Julia come out, talk about this stuff,
say it's basically over.
Okay.
Now, we've had a couple people comment since,
but today, >> congratulations. W's in the chat for >> the
guy, the guy himself who always finds the documents. Okay, we
had NMP. We had, sorry, not NMP. We had Henry Resilient himself
come in and say very, very specifically, all right, did I say
NMP? Henry Resilient himself came in and said, "Okay, it is it
is over. It seems to be coming to an end." And he's got some
more documents for us. Okay, we got more documents,
few more weeks before the judge gives their final word. I don't
think so. I think this one is actually coming to a close. Now,
there was a soda popin clip that I found as well that went along
with this. Uh Nick's been dodging their podcast for a little
while, right? Maybe a little >> maybe a little sick over
what the settlement will be precisely. It seems
>> I don't think he's going to be on the podcast today.
Uh oh. Oh yeah, I'm going to have to go. Uh I have a podcast
tonight. I can do a full six hour stream, but keep that in mind.
So do Ryan podcast. I think Ryan's going to be on the podcast.
Any Ryan's gonna be on it regardless. On the podcast. O
>> Oh, here we go. That's That's where it actually goes.
>> Come on the podcast. Oof. Right here. That'd be a spicy
one when she gets her half. I think she's going for more than
half. Now,
I think that's true. Once we go through this, I think that is
true that she's seeking I I believe 60% of the assets. Okay.
And for me personally,
I don't think that's necessarily wrong. And I would want to talk
to anybody who thinks that's like necessarily wrong. You know
what I'm saying?
Like anybody who thinks that that's just totally incorrect. It's
totally up that she's getting 60. I would want to talk to anyone
who who thinks that cuz to me, she invested in this business.
She built this business with
NMP. That business is going to continue over time, right? I'm
trying to think of how it's different between her and
what's the difference between her and Nick Lee. I'm trying to
think cuz I was thinking about this a little bit more.
Nick's business, like his his channel is as good as it's ever
been,
right? There's a massive massive income stream there still.
So, I think if they wanted to split 50/50, then that's fine,
but she should be getting cut like residual checks from the business,
right, that she helped
Like, I think she basically comes in, she puts equity in, she's
building this business out with him from the time he's like a
thousand viewer streamer until he's like a 20,000 viewer streamer.
And I think she should get some equity going forward. And if
he wants if he wants to buy her out of that, then probably it
ends up not being 50/50 precisely,
Molina is filing for Okay. Well, we'll see that in the video.
Yeah, we'll see that in the video then. But I just I don't think
it's necessarily wrong to file for >> I think I remember
asking Nick specifically, can I ask or say that? He's like, yeah,
I think you can. I don't know. It's It's a tough thing. It's
a legit court case, but I think it's coming to a close. Thank
god. Why' you say that? match back end is so
>> Well, I think Nick's trying to give her half and she's
been declining it.
>> Oh, the one thing I will say I think I think Nick's
like lying about how much money he's got to tell you the truth.
I saw I saw like a breakdown of the assets. We'll see that eventually.
I think he's hiding wealth for sure. I think there's like a lot
of wealth getting hidden there. I don't think he's like gigah
rich. I don't think he's got like I I I
think the the total assets was like 1.6 million and I'm like
no you got more than 1.6 million in assets. I'm almost positive.
I feel like you got 5 to 10. Maybe not quite 10. I think five
is
Yeah, we'll get into that burrito fritter as we go along. Let's
just get into the video. Okay, let's get into the video. Let's
start talking about it. If she finds hidden assets, she could
get it all. Well, I don't know if she will find them, but Nick's
talked about stuff and I do wonder if the asset splits like show
any of the he's referred to because he talked about buying a
bunch of Nvidia really early and I'm like, dude, if you bought
like 10 or $15,000 in Nvidia stock in 2020,
like that's a lot of money. That's that's like two 300 grand
now, isn't it? >> Congratulations. W's in the chat for
Nick because the court session, trial, whatever you want to call
it, is officially over. The uh divorce stuff is finally uh coming
to a close. We are just waiting on uh the judge's uh I guess
final verdict I suppose. >> You sure about that? You sure
about
>> Hold on. >> I suppose you got to listen to that
again and I got to see this. Okay.
>> 2 days 3 hours set by parents divorce
civil settings for district court on MARCH 23RD, 2026. OH, I
see. They've got one more thing. Now, is that just basically
the judge setting down his ruling on what the asset split will
be
>> We'll see. Henry will explain that. >> It's safe
to say I am living in Nick's head rentree. >> Invite Henry
Resilient on the pod. Don't want to lose views. You know, we're
already struggling enough. We don't need to go down to 200. So,
we're good on >> He even talks about me in his Discord,
pointing out my 200 view live stream covering his court documents.
My tweets are not getting much engagement. weird to think about
him and his soldiers that are tracking my online activity. And
according to him, I'm a total failure. >> Yeah, I ain't
going to lie, I'm getting >> He even suggested
that he would himself if he had my same views. Now, I think that
this is ironic because this was the same week he said he thought
about putting a mix skill and driving into traffic, taking his
life and the life of others. How am I doing? I'm doing pretty
good, all things considered, man.
Career's dead, but other than that, life's going pretty good,
>> bro. Career is not dead. All you got to do is stream,
man. I get that it's stressful. Okay, I have I have empathy for
Nick that it's stressful. He's going through this divorce and
he doesn't want to stream as much. He doesn't feel it as much.
He doesn't have the passion. Okay, I I get it, man.
But the career is not over. A bunch of people want to watch your
stuff. You've got a huge fan base,
bro. What's the worst case? I think these people just need the
confidence that they could like have their audience cut in half
or something, which I don't think has even happened to Nick,
by the way. But you could have your audience cut in half and
still come back from that.
If you've got like a 100 people who will show up to watch your
stuff, you can grow,
especially if you're entertaining enough to build it once, you
could totally build it again. You just got to find a niche and
keep going. >> I've had some dark thoughts, you know, when
I'm driving on the highway and I see some headlights. I'm thinking
about turning straight into them. But hey, that's a part of being
an adult, right, guys? If you do not know me, >> dude.
No way with the snort.
Oh my
Oh my goodness. >> Was a streamer who drove the wrong way
on a freeway, taking his life and the lives of other people.
>> Welcome back. The driver in a horrific war crash that
three people in California Thursday has been identified. 18-year-old
Trevor Heightman was behind the wheel of the $200,000
clearance sports car.
You know, I hopefully if this does Alician Baiton, if you think
about it, it sounds exactly like things that Misfit used to do.
>> You know, I hopefully if this does happen, no one else
is in the car.
>> What about the poor souls he's thinking about driving
into? I'm sure this is just another edgy Nick Palom joke that
we just, you know, we just don't get. But men who go through
divorce are more likely to unalign themselves, but it's
>> Okay, so $100,000 of Nvidia in 2020 would be 3 million
today. Yeah, that's about what I thought. Like 20x, 30x.
And he said he bought a decent a chunk. That might mean like
20k by the way. But that's still like that's basically all of
the assets there. Maybe they diversified it though after it was
>> like the 9 to5 guys make you know living paycheck to
paycheck. Not the multi-millionaires who will still be a millionaire
after divorce. Or maybe not. According to his proposed divorce
settlement where he tries to convince the judge and likely tries
to convince Molina too that he's only worth about 1.7 million.
Then he corrects the value to 1.66 million. But I'm no accountant,
but both spreadsheets seem to have a
calculation error in his favor. And you know, once you know you
see it, it'll be completely obvious to you. Stick around to the
end of the video. I'll repost his entire proposed divorce settlement
spreadsheet, and maybe some accountant can look it over and fact
check me if I'm right or wrong. Going back to Nick, it's safe
to say he's just sympathy for him like Msk would do. If you ask
Noro, who was mentioned in his divorce, she would say that there's
really no difference between Msk and Nick Blom. He even pointed
out that there is literally no difference between one of her
followers going from Miz frog to NMP >> from Denmark to
US. What a downgrade. Oh.
Oh, it was someone else's frog earlier. Had to change. Oh my
god. I see your picture, bro. I know what kind of frog you were
before. Dude, you should you should have changed your name to
Norah Frog 69. But I'm telling you, man, you're missing out cuz
you you you really just switched from
one to another. You I'm telling you, you didn't help yourself,
brother. Speaking of Biffk, he continues to troll everyone about
the Imaru case. >> Still in a restraining order. What's
it been like 2 and a half months? Interesting, right? Saying
you're in the process of filing restraining order, but no intention
of ever doing it is evil >> So, it's only fitting for Ms.
Keif to finally enter the divorce of Molina and Nick Palone's
fallen, but I'm not sure ever was really
>> The Miz stuff is funny. Um,
man, Miz watching his clip with Ice Boseidon was very funny.
Okay,
we'll get we'll get to that in the ice section a little bit later
today, but oh my goodness, it was it was man, his reaction was
weird. It was weird to say the least. >> Which was likely
Nick's strategy considering the final trial date was rapidly
approaching. I wonder if Molina knows who are the other owners
of OTK and I guess she knows how many shares that Nick has or
they have. But what about the others? Because according to Nick's
spreadsheet, he owns about 480,000
common shares in which he hopes the judge will allow him to transfer
50% of those to Melena and in the interim allow him to be the
trustee for the Melena as in to you know make decisions on the
best interest of her and him for the company. What happens if
she wants to sell those shares? That's a great question. Before
we get into the divorce, let's address Asmin Gold coping with
the fact that NMP's online reputation is trash. as Mongold I
get but NMP everybody thinks that Nick is this bad terrible person
because he's had a couple of bad clips on LSF but Nick has actually
been a really nice guy to me I've known him for years and I think
that really um the the Nick hate and stuff like that that happens
is in my opinion kind of overdrawn the NMP and Asmin go hate
is not the same as not encouraging his followers to brigade posts
or argue on his behalf on Reddit and Twitter and 4chan I imagine
if some of his fans of Asingo posted proof of them telling people
to end their lies for calling him out. I don't think he they
would get a soldier tag. Maybe him or his mom would like ban
him if he actually ever sees it himself. But Nick sees it differently.
Nick rewards that behavior, like I said, with a soldier role
in his Discord server.
Man,
uh I get where Henry's coming from, okay, that he's like doing
the review of the whole divorce up to this point.
I do I do get it a little bit, but this is um this is a lot of
farming here. There's a lot of farming on the old stuff. I'm
get We'll see. I'm going to start I'm going to go a little fast
through this. I might speed it up cuz I don't mind the review,
okay? For especially for people who are unaware. It's good to
get a little bit of the
>> My hate is justified. He earned it all the way back
to threaten the LSF mods with his FBI connections. >> The
mod coming forward with evidence of misk pressuring mosque with
his friends NMP where NM even threatened a mod that he got connection.
>> Remember this girl? This girl just disappeared out of
nowhere. She came and she went. >> FBI open the door. Boom.
Boom. Boom. Boom. This is the same guy who thought joking about
kids losing their life to a flood was edgy and he only apologized
because he got backlash. Nick is the type of guy to tell his
audience there's no drama in this divorce. >> But I can't
say there's no like fighting or anything. So if anyone's looking
for fighting or drama, it's not going to it's not there. >> After
he locked out his Soon and ex-wife of all their financial accounts
>> Nick is the same guy out here saying he's happy to pay
her half while intentionally dragging out the divorce process,
refusing to share financial information about the
>> That is true that he like she was she had access to
nothing which is kind of rough. I do I still think that to me
it seems pretty clear that there's got to be more there that
hasn't been
it just straight up like hasn't been
uh how do I put it? Yeah, it just hasn't been discovered. I I
wonder how he's hiding it or if he is hiding it specifically.
I feel like there's got to be something.
Uh YouTube demonetized her last I heard and she quit. Oh many
such >> as well as ownership stake in >> That's rough,
man. I'm thankful that I've made enough money in my life to handle
paying uh lawyer fees. >> Then he calculates what their
her looks like, right? But he fails to incorporate two large
accounts in the calculation that totals over $450,000
as part of their divorce settlement. He does not want to pay
her anything, guys. He tanked their Twitch channel when he learned
that half of the revenue was going to hurt her. >> Yeah,
that's still loser mindset, though. I I I got to keep it a bucket.
That is still loser mindset though. >> Bro is too stupid
to understand Texas divorce, but I'm not going to explain it
to him. I'm just going to let him be mad cuz he's dumb.
Someone knows how to look up laws. Congrats. We have a winner.
Everything he earns is subject to being included in the award.
Oh, dude. It's so stupid that he was putting this out there in
the Discord, right? Like
that will be negatively looked at by the judge. If the judge
sees that you're like intentionally not streaming, you just don't
want to like do your job.
Like imagine somebody who just quits their job because they're
getting divorced and they don't want their wife to get any more
money. Like I feel like you get penalized harder for that. That
could add that could I think
contribute to him basically losing even more like getting the
60% losing the like getting 6040 instead of 50/50. >> 50%
of something >> is at least something
>> nothing is nothing at the end of the day. Okay, bro.
you guys and everyone was making jokes about my 50% cuz I knew
I was never going to I knew I was never going to lose that cuz
I there was no claim for marriage in my case and I knew for a
fact but even then it's still a thought that was looming that
like wait I could be like wait I could be right now I could be
working for somebody else technically if like that to go through
or whatever and it didn't matter not even a single day I went
like well then I'm not going to do that then I'm not going to
I'm not going to I'm not going to show up and I'm not going to
do my thing that's like that's like loser mindset doesn't matter
I'm still being productive I'm still acquiring experience I'm
still doing something that matters that that that's building
towards a goal you can chunk He doesn't doesn't you you can chunk
half of a golden egg. Okay, we can't chunk half of a golden goose.
Okay, unless the golden goose stops getting the golden goose.
>> Hey, hold on. >> What? What? >> This came
off the heels of him talking about how he was going to be streaming
more to pay for the divorce. >> Planning on getting a car
for drifting? >> Am I planning on getting a car for drifting?
Oh. Oh, you haven't heard jumpy? Yeah, we were pretty much out
of
>> we lost like a whole bunch of money, 50% and then, you
know, we ditched for a while. So we we kind of have to grind
for like at least the next 6 months before we can even do anything.
>> He's the same guy asking for the case to be sealed so
the audience don't see what Molina is saying in her divorce filance
as she amended her divorce petition.
>> XQC was just saying it's really stupid to like your
own stuff to like spite your wife. That's all he was saying >> two
times right now. The second one she accused him of wasting money
on his girlfriend. It's catchy. I guess she's going to be Molina
part two when they get married. I'm sure he's going to do a prenup.
He agreed not to talk about the divorce online, but now people
are seeing what's happening in this divorce. So, he filed literally
to remove the gag order. I didn't get a chance to cover this,
but on November 14th, 2025, he literally applied to dissolve
the temporary injunction that bars him from speaking with hopes
that the court dissolve the above reference temporary mutual
injunction or the alternative that the court can modify the same.
He
>> I'd like to think that Nick basically,
you know, he allowed this at first and now I feel like he's like,
"Oh my god, look at how much content it is covering your divorce.
I need to COVER IT.
LET ME COVER it >> about the case publicly." And since
he can't do that, he's using people like his orbiters to talk
about it, which we will get to. >> When's Bla come on the
podcast? O,
that'd be a spicy one when she gets her half. I think she's going
for more than half. I think I remember asking Nick
>> dude. Do you think,
I do wonder. The tactics are pretty universal. It's very funny.
>> Say that. He's like, "Yeah, I think you can." I don't
know. It's It's a tough thing. It's a legit court case, but I
think it's coming to a close. Thanking God. Why' you say that?
Well, I think Nick's trying to give her half and she's been declining
it. >> I don't know. It's like It's >> Asmin go trying
to convince people that the people that hate him and NMP and
Hassan for the same reasons. That's simply not true. >> On
LSF hates Nick, I I get why LSF hates Nick. I get why they hate
me or they hate Hassan. I understand why. But this is one thing
that a lot of like viewers might not understand is that the persona
you see online is not the persona behind closed doors. It's exactly
like he's a normal person, right? You won't get it because you
don't know them. Yes. Exactly. You don't actually know them.
>> They're all different and people dislike them for different
reasons. Lastly, even Nick, right, admits to going through LSF
to report posts that document his actions to LSF mods to try
to find a loophole to get these same post removed. >> Anyone
there? >> Do I know anyone LSF? >> Yeah, I know them.
Yeah, that's that's public knowledge. >> Oh, okay. >> But
like like it's simple cuz like the way the way it works on the
website is they have like if you right click report, it gets
put in a mod. >> I see. >> Okay. So, a post is up
and they haven't cleaned out the mod for 3 hours. Well, then
it's been up for 3 hours. So, there there's like rules on LSF.
You can just read them and if I if I see a post that is about
me that violates one of the rules, you're damn right I report
that [__] Okay. For sure.
Okay, this is uh maybe this guy can't make it cuz this is like
super filtered behavior.
You shouldn't be doing this if you're trying to build something.
It's like you're not helping yourself. It like makes you It's
like one of those things
like those posts are almost like um
like chickenpox or something that you're scratching, right? You're
like scratching and all it does is make you like itchier. You
just like focus more on it. you scratch it more and then eventually
you're like bleeding and you just keep like scratching. No, no,
no, no, no. It's not helpful. It doesn't help you get better.
Focus on something that like helps you get better, right? I understand
like exactly why he does it that it like hurts his feelings.
It makes him upset. He's not being looked at in a favorable light.
I get it, but like you can't focus on that stuff. If you focus
on that stuff, it will break you. Is this from personal experience?
Well, it's from personal experience of me being like, "Okay,
I see something that annoys me. It like makes me upset,
but I can then go, "Okay, well, I shouldn't like I literally
am not going to comment on it." Right? You see, so like this
is my personal philosophy, right?
It's why I've had like stuff pop up and I'm like, "Okay, I'll
talk about it once and then I'm not talking about it again."
It's it's Yeah, it's obviously you you don't give in to all of
these things, right? If you if you all if all you do is give
people like if you validate the idea that you'll answer like
all these criticisms and you'll constantly get upset about them,
then people will do it constantly, you'll just enter a loop of
that. You have to have some point where you're like, "Okay, I'm
ignoring it now." You like basically talk to people about it
once and then if other if other people are just like trying to
upset you, you just move on. It's no point.
>> Very sad. >> Sure. I I remember sad watching you.
Well, I guess you go through like the normal Well, it's not the
normal. I'll be like, "Hey, look at this post. I report it. This
is the rules I think it violates." You know, >> like he's
actually just saying to people that, "Yeah, LSF posts about me.
They really upset me and I'm probably going to do something about
it." And then he like trashes out in his Discord. He's all over
the place. >> But the thing is, if they if if they don't
if he doesn't if he doesn't break the rules, they don't take
it down. >> Who cares if Nick is nice to Asmin go, his
business partner, and his friend, when he conducts himself like
the insecure 12-year-old he is, mad at the world. Now, look,
I personally do not care for Asmin go's anecdotal testimony that
Nick has been nice to him. Asmin go, I know you may be watching
this not on stream, but [__] has not been so nice
to me. He accused me of lying when he knows I'm just showing
the same court docs that he receives that he sent out. >> Listen,
you guys call me an idiot for getting another another lawyer
to explain stuff, but you guys are the same people that listen
to Henry Brazilian and think he's telling the truth. Hello. Like,
you call me the idiot. Look at the >> Thank god XQC defended
me, but I'm not even sure if that's enough. I have no idea what
impact I have on
um people
that I should have zero impact
>> Here it is, man. >> Yo yo, if you know, you know.
If you know, you know. >> You see it in 4K. Uh my man Nick,
my main man Nick,
he's actually stressed >> I don't think a lot of people
know. >> he's trying to find happiness and he knows it's
not coming anytime soon. So, what does he do? He's lashing out
on me. That That's fine, man. I mean, I put up I put up something.
I got up. >> Guys, this guy this guy does a court review
or whatever and his his commentary actually ends up impacting
the case itself in some form of capacity, which I think is crazy
to think about. Just by him looking at the doc on stream, it
has it actually interferes with the process. >> 128 views.
>> I could see that interfering with XQC's thing cuz I
think XQC's thing got sealed pretty quickly. I guess Nick did
too. I don't think it interferes with the process, but it does
make people more aware. And if people are going to, you know,
like here's how it would interfere is you basically make people
aware of the case. They look into it themselves. They find something
they think is relevant. They send it to one of the parties, right?
Like that is technically interfering, but it's if it's just information
that's valid or relevant, then I I don't really consider that
interfering, right? Like that's that's not interfering. You can
call it interfering and you especially feel like it's interfering
if it's going to the other side of whatever court case you're
on, but I don't think it's interfering. Now, if people were sending
you or sending the other people threats,
um threats or lies or like bad information, then that's interfering
with the case obviously, right? >> So, I know he's going
to be like, "Hey, he couldn't even muster uh that many views."
Shout out to Black. Henry Resilient lives in his head. Rimfree.
Yes. Yes. Yes. Very true. Very, very true. Henry is Nick's boogeyman
and it's entertaining to watch. >> I wouldn't say I'm his
boogeyman, but when a video drops about him, he knows like [__]
He knows guys I don't know I don't want to do with the neck but
I I don't know what some of these is. >> Speaking of XQC
he is right. I just read the court docs and as a result Nick
is trying his hardest to seal the court docks. Even right now
he's probably punching the air doing his whole divorce settlement
is public record and is about to be seen for the first time.
Now this could be a lesson for all you to learn from of why you
probably should stay away from marriage. According to Julia NMP
orbiter doing shipping content with Mr. Arthur NMP's divorce
trial is over. Congratulations. W's in the chat for Nick because
the court session trial, whatever you want to call it, is officially
over. The uh divorce stuff is finally uh coming to a close. We
are just waiting on uh the judge's uh I guess final verdict,
I suppose. >> Well, why are you hearing this from her and
not from Nick? Remember, Nick is still prohibited from making
public statements about the divorce, which he is hoping to overturn.
He's likely to tell his closest orbiters what to say, what not
to say. But that's where I come in, right? I will show you all
the or the most relevant court docs that I have pertaining to
it. And when they talked about the Escalade with the Starlink
being for sale, >> Cadillac Escalade 2023 equipped with
a beautiful Starink generation 2 full size. Um,
it is no more. It is getting sunseted very soon. >> Yeah,
that's about true. Now, let's get into this case.
>> Was Julia allowed to say that? I don't
And like I don't know. So, here's
uh here's how it works. I think I think you're allowed to talk
in private about your case and then technically it's like somebody
else's free speech. So, as long as you don't tell them like as
long as you don't tell them explicitly like talk about this or
like as long as you don't basically tell that person what to
say about your case, it's like ambiguous in the eyes of the law.
And probably you could try to look into that and see if they're
if the other person like you could probably subpoena text messages
or something. But if they just talk in person, you have no idea
what's going on there. It's while it might not be allowed for
them to go and like discuss all these things and then the other
person's like, well, I'm going to talk about this
now. Julia, I think up a little bit here where she says I'm allowed
to say it, right? God bless the First Amendment. Wait, hero is
overdosing. Do you think it's God bless the First Amendment when
people leak things on Turkey to Tom?
when people leak things and it hurts a guy or you W first amendment
when it's being used to help a guy in his divorce. Yeah. Okay.
As long as you're as long as you're even. As long as you're evenhanded
here.
That's why Te stopped streaming. Well, yeah. I don't think Tone
had people around him who wanted to pick up all of his and start
discussing it on streams,
right? But Teone couldn't stop talking about it himself. That
was his problem. >> So, if you guys don't know, if you
haven't been following, Molina did file a second amended petition
for divorce. Right now, what is this? When she filed this, this
is her saying, "Hey, she wants to change something." She actually
filed a third amended petition for divorce, but we have to get
it. So, what what changed from her first filing to her second
filing? Well, this part right here, she's looking to get some
benefits because she's innocent. Remember, she accused them of
cheating. Uh, also, we already know about her benefits. The innocent
spouse may have derived from the continuation of the marriage.
Disparity of earning power of the spouses and their ability to
support. Earning power, businesses, opportunities, capacities,
and abilities of the spouses. Nature of property involved in
the division. Waste. Attorney's fees
from her first filing to her second filing. Well,
>> okay. Molina Pollm requests the court consider the following
and affecting division of the party's estate. Respondents economic
financial abuse of petitioner. Respondent's failure to permit
access to the party's community property accounts, including
for the purpose of insight and access to such community funds.
benefits of the in benefits the innocent spouse may have derived
from the continuation of the marriage that is earning potential
from the channel and stuff before all this happened and that
he will have the earning power going forward. >> This part
right here, she's looking to get some benefits because she's
innocent. Remember, she accused him of cheating. Uh also, we
already know about her disparity of earning power based on him
having a company and her not having anything for the most part.
The nature of the property involved in the division. Uh waste.
Waste is new. Waste is something we're going to have to talk
about in a little bit more deeper detail. I want to talk about
what I think is an underutilized claim in Texas divorce cases.
Often get asked from parties and usually it's women that if their
husband is cheating or has been cheating, is there a way to get
them an unequal division? >> Uh, one second. I just need
to be right back. Give me two seconds. I'll be right >> Is
cheating or has been cheating? Is there a way to get them an
unequal division of the assets? Meaning that they think I should
get more because he's a cheater. Adultery alone is not a reason
for an unequal division of assets. So my answer is usually no.
But what I think is very underutilized is a waste claim. You
can make a waste claim if your husband has been spending assets
unbeknownst to you on a mistress. So ex takes his mistress to
Tahiti
and um that's something that you can make a claim for and get
your half back. Women need to know that. >> Also, she added
NPO LLC to the case. It's officially a party to the case because
this is a business that they own and she's looking for information
about it which I'm not sure she ever got originally. Maybe not.
So what what is she saying with waist? Throughout the party's
entire marriage, Nicholas Palom squandered community assets by
making grossly excessive expenditures on paramores rent business
trips and himself. She contests that he spent literally money
that she would have never agreed to. She's >> Dude, I knew
it. I knew it. I knew it, guys. I knew he's going to going to
get penalized that this would get brought up, right? You can't
do this in a divorce. You can't go Well, my wife's trying to
take half, so I'm going to go on a spending spree.
Um, who do we have in this? I still think Molina should rob this
blind on greed alone.
Um, yeah. I mean, I think Molina was more than entitled to 50%.
The issue for me is how do you make Molina whole when she didn't
want the relationship to end? She didn't want the marriage to
end. and he cheated on her and she was 50% involved in that business
by and large. Like the the the
majority of that channel's like most successful lifespan, she
was very involved, right? Like basically 50/50 partners, they're
working on it together. So she would have continued to benefit
from that channel existing and all of this, right? He shut down
the YouTube channel as well. That's what So I think in terms
of their assets they'd earned, she's now losing out on the earning
potential of a business she helped build,
right? And he's going to have all the earning potential after
that. So it's going to be about I guess what the judge thinks
there. And then I guess infidelity allows her to go for more.
And then I'm guessing she'll be able to go for even more if he
was making like gross like large purchases. Like I'm guessing
there will be even more money there to to try to go after. Oh
man. So I think I she's going 6040. That's what she's trying
to go for. I think Nick,
so I'm guessing the asset split I saw was about 1.6 million split
two ways. 8 800,000 both of them, right? They both get 800,000.
And I think that was proposed by Nick. But I think that's
I I I don't know, but I think that's because he's hiding assets.
I just can't see 1.6 million being all of his monetary assets
that exist in the world. I can't I can't see it. That seems crazy
to me. >> He's not going to agree to say, "Hey, spend this
amount of money on Kochi getting her a Chanel bag that cost
>> Spend 30 minutes talking about talking about a a very
expensive purchase. >> You're so dumb. >> Hell no.
Or these gambling trips." So, she wants to be reimbured for that.
Now, of course, in true Nick Palone fashion, he responded saying,
"Hey, give her nothing. He don't He >> You going to have
a percentage of the revenue. 30% is fair." Uh, yeah. Yeah, if
Nick wanted to do that, if he wanted to go 50/50 and then she
gets 30% of the revenue going forward. Absolutely. I think I
think she should take that. But I think that would be way more
money than what she's going to get just splitting 60/40 to be
honest with you. So, I think Nick won't want that. >> Yeah.
Look, trust me, he don't want her seeing not a penny from anything.
But, you know, it's the law, so he has to. As we move forward,
this is him trying to get the gag order lifted. Now, when it
comes to the divorce, it's been going on for a while, and I'm
sure Nick would love for everyone to think that it's being dragged
out for her for her financial gain to hit the 10-year mark. And
sure, that can be the case. But on paper, there's a different
story. See, according to her November filing, she >> Oh,
if the marriage hasn't been dissolved by the 10-year mark, does
that again increase the amount of money she could get? I think
that's typically the way it works in a lot of divorces is there's
like a there's a limit to doing like a full 50/50 asset split,
I think, or or with regards to like alimony, I think around 10
years, there's there's like a cliff where you can ask for more.
So, it's possible she's trying to drag it out to that. >> She's
having to file these motions to compel to get documents from
Nick because he was supposed to turn over all his financial records
on the 25th as it says right here. But the problem is that didn't
happen. There were some deficiencies, right? What did he not
share with her? First and foremost, right here, the closely held
and unincorporate business entities. What does that mean? She
is looking for documents right on OTK Media Inc. Who owns it?
How many people what what shares they have? He's like, "Hey,
look, documents confirming that OTK Media Inc. holds 100% ownership
of the following ventures. OTK Ventures and OTK Studios. She
technically she's a owner of OTK via Through Nick. And she's
like, "Hey, um I still don't know what we own." >> The
other thing that would be very interesting is all of his friends
are in this company. They probably support him 100%. I wonder
how much those friends would let him allow him to use like OTK
purchases to basically like use OTK lines of credit to make purchases
and stuff that he could keep like off the record or whatever
is going on. Like basically would they allow him to hide as much
of his income as possible within those corporations? Would they
care? That's that would be very concerning to me. I think it's
totally fair that they ask, you know, can we see the balance
sheets of all these companies? You have major ownership stakes.
>> So she's like, hey, I haven't got any of these things.
Nothing pertaining to OTK Ventures, OTK Studio, Red Tonic, Mad
Mushroom, Mythic Talent. Also, this is where the Mizkiff component
enters the >> I will expose everything about every person
that you've ever known. >> And it is time to go full demon
time. >> She is looking for, hey, what's going on with
the Minsk lawsuit >> right here?
>> She needs to know the current litigation with OTK. Nicholas
Palom has failed to produce the following. any information regarding
lawsuit filed against OTK Inc. Mythic Talent Management Inc.
and King Lab Gaming, which is Star Forge. She's like, "Hey, I
haven't got any of that." And as a result, she's like, "Look,
I want in order of him to provide this document.
Also, an admonishment by the court for fail to answer discovery
timely and fully can result any
I need you to go forward in the documents, which if they strike
it and just go by basically what she proposed as their half of
the settlement, that could be horrendous for Nick. But if the
judge does that in the end, whose fault is that? It's just his
blame. In order imposing Nick Palone pay her legal fees uh for
preparing this first amendment motion to compel. I mean, if this
is true, I think that's only fair. Now, going forward, December
9th, this was her third third amended petition for divorce or
my birthday of all day. >> Oh man, I don't even know if
we got this third amended petition. I do wonder how long it takes,
like how long these things stay under gag order or if Henry's
just like going over he's got four more documents here. I wonder
if we just got a dump cuz maybe the um maybe the gag order did
get dissolved at some point.
Should we look for this? Would this be on court listener or something?
I wonder if we should look for this and see. Does anybody want
to take a second and just try to see if they could find like
some of the court documents under these names?
Because I I think you could find them. I don't want to do it
on stream right now or totally ignore this, but I think you it's
possible that the gag order got dissolved and maybe this is all
just public filings now. We can look through >> What changed,
right? We all know she added, you know, Nicolone LC to the case.
That's good and dandy. Uh we know that they got married September
25th, 2025, 2015. They're celebrating 10 years of marriage. We
know about her adding, you know, the reasons why she should get
a disproportionate share. And unfortunately, guys, I hate to
tell you, but no agreement was made, even though she was hopeful,
but how can you agree to settle something if you don't have all
the information to make the informed decision? But most importantly,
what did she add? Two items. post divorce maintenance. She wants
that. Now, here's the thing. We already talked about in Texas
in order to get post divorce maintenance is pretty hard considering
it's a huge settlement that you're going to see is be roughly
$800 some thousand dollar as well as the fact they've been married
for 10 years that gives her a leg up. But the fact that the $800,000
settlement that's kind of going to, you know, take a take a hit
to it, but because this is going by a judge making a decision,
it's going to go by the letter of the law with the judge seems
fair fit for both parties. Is it fair that Molina just walks
away with $800,000, which I believe $185,000 is in assets, the
rest is in cash, some stock options and OTK and maybe some Pokemon
or uh Magic the Gathering cards. Is that fair to her or is it
fair to Nick or should the judge say, "Hey, you got $800,000.
Figure it out. Why you need an extra? What you're going to realize
is she wants an extra $300,000 on top of that, which we will
get to. So, going back to that, after the post divorce maintenance,
which she's we're going to get into what she's specifically requesting,
she's also requesting a permanent gag order. She does not want
him to make any public statements, whether written or verbal
or visual, regarding the ongoing litigation of the party's divorce
unless mutually agreed to in writing by the parties filed with
the court." This is a bit much for a gag order. Furthermore,
strictly in the event the court does not grant the requested
permanent injunction, she has some other request to grant the
following permanent injunction in joint. I wonder if she proved
infidelity in court. I mean,
what is Nick going to say? I think this is why Nick was lying
about Kachi. But I think she basically had proof of infidelity
from the time they broke up. Like I think that's why they broke
up is because basically
I think there's a lot of evidence that he was hanging out or
he was going to like that Nora girl right before Kachi. I think
he was Yeah, he went to Europe for like Twitchcon. I think there
was something there like she got texts or something that made
it seem very likely that he was doing something with that Nora
girl >> enjoyments of parties their agents serves employees
basically friends to say look he enjoin him for making directly
or indirectly disseminating publish or causing to be published
or directly or indirectly requesting a person disseminate or
publish any letter story statement correspondence description
decept depiction of any kind whatsoever including any social
media formalized which could be reasonable interpreted as disparaging
or negative or defamatory in his description of other parties
personal professional private family life uh without limitation
the business or financial fails of the party basic Look, she
don't want anyone saying anything about her. You see how Julia
and MacArthur and Dean School are making all these statements
about the trial. Obviously, she probably wants none of that to
happen going forward where Nick is disseminating information
to them to put out for him to just simply repost on his own platform.
And we'll talk about that in freedom of speech in a later post
when we see her discrepancies put out. But most importantly,
something I want to point out to you. It's standard that she
wants him to cover legal fees. But most importantly, she wants
him to cover any expenses through trial and appeal should be
granted against Nicholas Palone in favor of her. So, in other
words, if the judge makes her decision, she's going to follow
appeal if, you know, maybe she feels it's not fair to her and
he may follow an appeal that is not fair to
>> Pretty sure Norah the Explorer still holds a grudge
against NMP because he dropped her for Kachi
makes jabs at him constantly. >> Should it be granted for
her against
>> I I do wonder, listen, that would be that would be quite
the uh problem for Nick, wouldn't it? If she was willing to go
over to Molina and be like, "Hey, here's all of our texts. Here's
everything we here's here's all of it." >> She wants him
to cover the appeal. This is major. So when the judge is making
this decision, she has to make the decision appeal proof.
>> Now as we continue, let's look at her disposition of
issues. These are the issues that she wants the judge to decide.
They had a hearing date on the 12. So this is likely what the
judge has to come to terms with as both parties made their arguments
of why it should happen. Obviously grant the divorce between
the parties from the grounds of insortability. I think this is
going to be granted. Slam. Both of a divorce. No need not to.
The tricky part award Molina 60% of the marrow estate and Nick
40% of the estate.
O that's that's the money shot right there. This the 60 versus
40. Okay, that's that's crazy, chat. That's as much as I think
I think there's a way to defend this. I think it's defensible.
I don't think it's crazy. Truly, I don't. Whoever gave my boys
lineup lined him up. Okay. All right, dude. You guys need to
chill in the hairline. This This is Henry brings us content and
you guys are going to go in on this guy's hairline. Really? great
shot at 60%. Reason being she could prove she could prove by
the letter of the law that he cheated. It's no shock that the
going forward what does her streaming career look like? She's
not going to have the connection. She's not going to have access
to the network and she's not going to make the same amount of
money without him by her side. You're kind of like a tag team.
So that's a leg up for her. But what do you think? Should the
judge give her 60% continue to go forward? She wants to be awarded
a disproportionate share of the party's estate for the following
reasons which we already went over. Now her being innocent that
should be a factor because technically she didn't cheat amongst
other things. But so this leaves the this opens the door for
the judge to award her let's just say 50 51% 55% 59% or on the
more extreme Ian 70% 80%. Now I don't think it it'll get there.
I think 60% probably would be fair. Probably the judge could
justify more than 50%.
wasted Christ that was way too fast. >> And if you want
to take in the financial abuse because I likely think that was
the whole claim that she was probably making as we continue.
She wants the order of the confirmation Molina separate property.
I think that's that's fairly standard. There's no no real value
there. Order Molina's waste claims for uh Nick Palum's assessed
expenditures. Basically, if the waste claims are granted and
that money goes back to Molina or at least half of what he spent
goes to Molina. So, if he spent 50,000 $100,000 on Gotchi over
the time that they were separated, she can expect 50,000 back
more than her agreed settlement because half that money was hers.
This is where you get to the the nitty-gritty. order Molina Palone's
request for post divorce maintenance for a period of 5 years
beginning February 1st 2026 in the amount of $5,000 a month.
So she basically went 60k a year or 300.
Now, I think at Nick's current earning potential, if he's making
if he's let's say he's making 25 grand a month at minimum, which
he should be making way more than that, right? He should be making
like 50 or 100 grand a month, I think, minimum.
If he's making 50 grand a month, you're taking 10%. I don't think
that's insane.
But again, I would I think I'd want something in here that says,
"Okay, I can't owe you this much if I'm not making anything close
to this, right?" like some sort of I I feel like you should have
some sort of protection thing in here that's like well if my
let's say my income dips for some reason I I don't want to have
to pay you. Although then she kind of has evidence that he's
willing to sacrifice his own business despite her. And I wonder
if that's like enough to say, "Okay, we're not going to we're
not going to put any floor in there like >> over 5 years
tax free. Remember, she meets the criteria 10-year marriage."
But because of this huge settlement, it'll be hard. I I'm not
sure how the judge will rule that. Twitter, Melena Palone be
granted judgment against Nicholas Palone with specific language
securing such interest against the shares in stocks held by Nick
Palone with his interest in OTK media and King Gaming Labs. In
other words, run her her 50% of the shares or more. She could
award more cuz she's asking for 60%. So, she wants her shares
of OTK and Star Force Systems to be secured. As we keep going,
I thought this one was a little bit outlandish. ordered that
any refunds received from the date of marriage through the date
of the divorce be divided equally by the parties with Melena
being entitled to 50% and Nicholas being entitled to 50%.
I think this is going to get denied outright to >> any
refunds received.
Day of the marriage through the date of the divorce be divided
equally. Refunds. I don't even Oh, income taxes. >> Go
back 10 years of tax returns and say, "Okay, well, you got a
return in this year, this year, this year, this year, and split
that 50/50." I think that's too too burdensome for anyone. I
don't think that >> Wait, why is that? That's
okay. Maybe this gets denied. But why is he saying that's burdensome
to calculate?
That seems crazy to me. No.
To just do a sum of 10 numbers from 10 years of tax returns.
How is that even a little bit burdenome to calculate? Yeah. Like
it it's literally like the easiest thing in the world if I I
just think that could be denied. I have no idea
because like what it's like after tax. It's it it should still
show up as like income somewhere like his bank statements or
something, right? That he's getting that back. I just don't understand
how the idea would be, oh, it's too hard to calculate that, so
he can't do it. I Yeah, >> just going to with that order
that any liability from the date of marriage to the date of birth
be solely by Nicholas. You know, my ex-wife tried to do this
to
>> That That one's No, no, no, no, no. That one's I feel
like that's like I think it should be a net, right? So what this
is saying is any debt that we had as a couple that any debt we
took out from the start of the marriage until the end of the
marriage should be held entirely by him. I don't think that's
true. I think what it should be is you take assets minus liabilities
and you just say that's the net, you know, assets of the estate.
I don't see why you would say, okay, we're going to take all
the assets, split them in half, and then all of the liability
goes to him. Unless that's maybe a part of if there's infidelity
involved.
I I think I don't think that's fair. I again I think that starts
to get into the realm of being unfair to me. >> The debt
and here's the thing when it comes to putting debt on someone,
right? Let's just say they both have credit card debt and sure
they're married. His debt is your debt. Your debt is her debt.
But in my state, when my ex tried to do this to me, there was
some law that said if I didn't benefit from the debt that she
took, then I'm not responsible for it. For example, if she went
out and bought a a new car and put that on a credit card, I'm
not responsible for half of it because one, it's not my car.
You kind of get the just like that. So, I don't think that all
the debt will be placed on Nick, but this is, you know, this
is why a judge exists because they wouldn't Nick wouldn't agree
to this. I would tell him like, "Dude, do not agree to that."
Order that the parties filed separate tax returns for 2026. Yeah,
I think that that's going to be granted with no qualms. Order
him being joined for making public. >> By the way, this
is the I I believe this is the third
amended divorce, right? No >> statements, whether written
or verbal. I think this is going to be denied.
>> I'm trying to think of like what this was when it got
filed here. Hold on. Number 2952.
Okay. 2952.
Molina Molina Pullum's disposition of issues. Hearing date January
12, 2026. So this is the hearing they had. Okay. So hopefully
if he has the outcome of this hearing, then that would be nice
cuz they must have they needed a hearing to litigate these things.
Got it. Got it. Got it. Got it. Got it. >> With no no qualms.
Order him being joined for making public statements whether written
or verbal. I think this is going to be denied. Why? Freedom of
speech. You have the right to say anything you want. It's your
god-given right in the United States. So, I think this is going
to be denied. Now,
>> uh you need to narrowly tailor this,
Uh making any public statements whether written. I mean,
yeah, it would be like disparaging statements or something along
these lines. Like, you'd need to more narrowly narrowly tailor
this. You can't have it be like totally open.
I think we've already seen that.
Listen, if Pixie got this this thing denied when Pixie's like
explicitly getting harassed by like a bunch of people, I haven't
seen like explicit harassment towards Melena, but if Pixie got
it denied, I can't see Molina getting it through here when Nick's
like not covered his divorce anywhere near as much. He hasn't
like maligned his wife anywhere near as much. I just can't see
it being the I can't see it being granted to be honest with you.
>> Strictly in the court does not grant it, you know, the
injunctions. Now, this would be granted in part, right? I have
something in my divorce clause that says this, right? I cannot
make any disparaging comments about my ex-wife. And I think this
is standard. So the judge is going to say, "Look, we're going to
grant this in part that he can't say anything negative or disparaging
about you on social media or through his friends." Sure, that's
going to be granted in part. But if he wants to come on the internet
and say yes in mediation, she asked for 70% or 60%. And how he
feel, he can stick to those facts. And that's what I would tell
him. Like as my attorney told me, if I'm going to talk about
my divorce publicly, I have to stick to the facts. Like there's
a fact that I pay 2 years of alimony. That's a fact. The fact
that I have 50/50 custody, I pay child support. That's a fact.
I don't agree with it, but you can't you could talk about the
facts, but you know, if you have a negative opinion of Molina
Nick after this, which I imagine you probably do, uh you kind
of want to keep that to yourself bare minimum. Keep it off the
internet. Now, obviously, she wants attorney fees. You know,
that's going to come off the community of them say their expenses.
Let's get to expense statements from both of them. This looks
like just a catchup on everything that's been in the uh in the
divorce so far.
>> Question because both of them have to create these expense
sheets to detail their spending. and in Melena case why she needs
more money and probably in Nick's case why he can't afford to
pay her spousal maintenance for the next 5 years. So when it
comes to Mel,
>> this is where all of the interesting stuff comes out.
>> She's saying her only source of income is the $7,500
a month coming in from Nick and via spousal support. And she
says, "Hey, this is what I get." But she's also saying her monthly
house payment is $54.85.
That is a lot of money for a house payment, especially when the
house is only valued at like $185,000.
>> that's not possible.
That's straight up not possible.
I don't know what's going on there.
That That's straight up not possible. It's I'm trying to think
of what that could possibly There must She must have to pay the
mortgage on like multiple houses or something. No, he's saying
it's 185,000, but I thought she's been living in Europe. I know
they bought a a house for their for her parents in Europe, right?
So, it's possible she's paying the >> This is a lot. This
is say like this is a little bit suspicious, but now the
>> Oh, the utilities are about normal for like a regularized
house, too, or apartment even.
>> Going to have to look over like everything that you
say you spend your money on. Now, you can say, "Hey, household
maintenance 60, internet, telephone." This is all standard stuff.
But when I when I go down to I see meals away from home, 200.
Hey, do we have to eat out every day? Uh, some other things that
I thought was
>> Do we have to eat out every day? $200 meals away from
home. That's not eating out every day. What's Henry saying,
bro? How much do you think it costs to eat away from home? Can
you have like a solo meal anywhere but McDonald's for less than
$20
anywhere?
Where does that even exist?
Can you have like like literally the cheapest food you can get
is like less slightly less than $20.
Yeah,
that's like most 10 days away from home. That's not even crazy.
600 bucks for
meals away from home. 200. Hey, do we have to eat out every day?
Uh, >> no. You You could not go to Chili's and get a meal
for less than 20 bucks.
I don't even know why you said Chili's. You're not even American.
Do you even have Chili's in England? Have you ever even been
to Chili's before? There's no way you could go to Chili and get
a meal for less than 20 bucks. >> Some other things that
I thought was excessive on Melena. And look, I got to call it
fair. You know, I'm supporting her getting at least 50%. Maybe
I maybe more, maybe like 60. Maybe I would be on board with 60,
right? She don't got she got nothing. And he's, you know, when
you see his divorce calculation, you gonna be like, "Okay, maybe
60% is fair." Things I don't agree with, 500 a month on entertainment.
Jesus Christ, Molly, what are you doing? 700 for personal hair
beauty stuff. That's excessive. And 200
I don't Man, is Henry really thinking about this? 500 for entertainment
a month. That's not that high. That's again not that high. You
go to the movies one time with another person, that's like what
in Canada it's like 60 bucks, 70 bucks,
maybe. Maybe that's a little high. No, that might not even be
high. It's like 50 bucks to go to the movies and get like maybe
60 if you get like popcorn and it's expensive as man.
I think Henry's like living in the past. Henry's living that
like that monk lifestyle, so he doesn't go out and do things
with other people, right? I'm talking about Canada, Sophia, just
so you know.
Henry's living that like monk lifestyle where he doesn't he's
not going out because he has to pay all of his divorce [__]
And so he is leave living like a totally aesthetic lifestyle
and can't understand what like things cost now. Erics, beauty,
personal care.
That might be high. I I don't know >> $100 on gifts. Like
are we literally buying gifts every month? That total $200 for
somebody. Is every every month someone's birthday? Probably not.
So this puts her total expenses at $9,000
43, you know, $9,4. >> Although, man, I look at my expenses
and they're not like this. I'm trying to think even without her
rent, I come in way lower than this, not including her rent at
all. >> $1,43
which puts her in a deficit of around $1,500. So, is she going
into debt every month? >> Uh,
no. I've been through this road. I know how it is. She's going
to put Why >> It's all the house payment. The house payment
was the only thing that seemed absurd to me there. The house
payment was way up there. >> Needs the money and maybe
inflate her numbers. and he's going to put well he can't pay
her because and he's going to deflate his earning potential which
you may seem you may catch right out the gate. So, when it comes
to Nick's uh his expenses, you're going to see he pays >> 5,000
a month. 5,000 a month, bro. Get the out of here, Nick. Oh my
god. Are you serious, dude?
No shot. No
shot on this planet Earth does he say that the amount of money
he makes a month is $5,000.
That's crazy.
That's out of this world.
That's embarrassing for him to try to say, man, >> roughly
$5,000. That's what he pays himself. So on paper, according to
this, he's probably making
>> I Are you telling me I make more streaming than Nick
Poll does?
I make more money streaming than Nick does.
That seems completely insane.
That seems totally insane.
There's no possible way. >> $60,000 a year. >> I
get that's what he pays himself. I'm saying he's not including
anything else here. all their income actually received. And by
the way, it would have to be the average of the last year or
something, too. Or or it would be reasonable to do the average
of the last year, not when he decided he was going to stop streaming
because of the >> which I think we all know that's cat.
>> See, now that's
>> We'll get to how he's doing it. So, as we continue to
go down, notice, remember how he did that stream was like, "Oh,
I have to pay rent now." That was just for this. That's why I'm
alone in this big old house. >> Yeah. Just rub in your
big old house. Why don't you? >> That you live in rentree.
>> No, actually, actually, during the divorce, I actually
uh I actually have to pay rent now. Dude, this guy is so stupid.
This guy is so stupid. This guy is so dumb. Are you serious?
You understand what he just said, right? That he used to live
here for free and now during the divorce I pay the rent. As in,
I'm going to take the $2,000 I would spend, I'm going to pay
it to like OTK or some [__] right? Whoever owns the
house, and yeah, now I pay rent. This guy's a [__]
He should actually say, "No, judge. I'm I'm putting a gag order
on myself.
Are you serious, Nick? This guy is so dumb.
Why are people this evil? Uh, Jorge the First, it's because they
had a marriage. They had a very close marriage and it broke broke
up. They broke up and there's nobody who could hurt you like
the people you care about the most, right? That's why divorces
turn so ugly is cuz you you share everything you're upset about
in the world with this person. You are super close to them. They're
the person who like would never ever hurt and then they are hurting
you repeatedly. Like that's I understand exactly why people get
evil during divorces. Even Nick, like I don't think this is like
outside the realm of normal human behavior.
It's totally within the realm of normal human behavior. He's
just for saying so on stream. Like I think this would get sniffed
out anyway. But my god, you are so dumb to say this directly
on a stream. You're out of your mind.
>> Oh yeah. >> Wait. Not only that, not only that,
Chance is collecting back pay. >> No, wait. Wait. >> I'm
losing all this money. It's all >> Wait, hold on. Hold
on. You're getting back paid, too? How much? How many >> Like
two years. Yeah. And all the bills, too. Yeah. >> Got to
pay it all. Yeah. >> Was it a lot? >> Oh, yeah. >> Oh,
dude.
Dude, why are you talking American makes a year? Yeah. Gone.
>> God forbid he went up in there like, "Oh, yeah. Soda
pop let me live free in his house. I don't pay no rent." He put
Sodap Pop and pays all the all the bills and I pay nothing for
rent. I imagine Melena in court brought this up that there was
no money ever discussed. Okay, maid cleaning. I mean this I mean
can we clean up ourselves as a streamer? Probably not. Now I
get as a streamer you have these expenses uh especially
>> dude a,000 a month for the maid. I'm trying to think.
Maid comes they clean for what? Two hours. They go once a week.
Two hours once a week.
So four and a half times a month. Two hours at $50 an hour. Dude,
I can't 50. Is the maid making more than 50 an hour? Two times
a week. You needed two times a week, bro. What? They had them
twice a week. Is he paying for Is he the only one in the house?
>> Internet things I didn't agree with. I'm like, "Bro,
you spending $500 a month on clothes? Like a washing machine?"
>> House might be huge if he's living alone in the house.
Why is the maid cleaning the whole house? Why is the maid going
to every room in the house every time she's there?
$1,000 is reasonable for that house. Maybe it's possible to get
more than one maid to come through. >> Just don't exist.
I I suppose also $400
>> because he's rich. Hold on. He's not rich. According
to his divorce statements,
he's not rich. According to his divorce statements, he's losing
$23,000 a month. Apparently, he's not rich. He only makes five
grand a month. He makes $60,000 a year, according to his divorce
statements. How do you, as a judge, not just like lose your mind
seeing this with all of the all the evidence he's put on the
record? How do you not just like lose your [__] on
Nick?
Like why are you wasting my time putting these fake ass documents
in here when I could see everybody could see like the lifestyle
you lived? Like you talking about money all over the place. How
much you make?
You buying what? Did he buy like a $13,000 bag for Kachi? I'm
pretty sure that's on stream, too. That he bought a $13,000 bag
for Kochi. He hasn't really streamed in like a year. That's That's
not Molina's fault. That's his fault.
That's literally his fault. And he has said explicitly that he
was streaming less because he didn't want her to get
>> for personal care and haircut. Bro, bro does not get
his haircut. Like, have you seen his hair? >> Who's cutting
that? Obviously, probably someone better than mine. But look,
don't don't worry. It's not about me right now. It's about Nick.
Focus on
>> That's wild with the the offset here. That's That's
>> Nick. Uh 1,500 a month. Like, what is up with what is
up with both of them in these exorbitant entertainment expenses?
These could be I thought Kachi was paying all the bills anyway,
right? travel $2,000 a month plus spousal support. So his
>> like to me if you come to me, I'm the judge and you
come to me and you say
like I'm actually $23,000 in the hole per month. That's what
I'm going to put as my income statement for my divorce.
I'm probably like, how do you even have the assets to be $23,000
in the hole? Like I'm Dude, I'd be so angry getting this and
reading it. Like you're just wasting my time. >> It's total
needed per month, including the spousal support payments, which
I thought came out the community funds. >> Nick, I audit
attorney fees. Look up legal audit services if they tell you
to pay for Molina's fees. >> It doesn't work that way.
It's all community estate. >> Uh $23,000 a month. All right.
$23,000
a month. And it looks like he has a
a credit card with a balance of $1,000
bringing his
like I feel like this was this was a
he filed a motion
to please me financially. Right? That's what this motion is.
That's what this like statement is. This income statement is
like please me financially.
Like I am clearly hiding income. There's clearly income I'm not
including in this divorce. There's clearly like things going
on here that I'm not going to include in this divorce. Please
audit literally everything I have. Please me, please, please,
please. That's what he's saying. I dude, this monthly payment,
$28,000. I'm not That's the average of the last three months.
So, you see him hyping it up. Hey, my monthly payment is
And they're just going to go with that number. They just going
to go with the go with the monthly monthly uh debts right here
to 28,000. Oh, it was 28,000 a month. Come on now, dog.
Come on, man. >> Like, how's Look, man. Like, Marty Bird
is probably cooking his books. >> Great. Get the out. Do
it. I don't need >> Based on this, right, difference between
the money received and the money needed, do you think he's going
in debt? Roughly, you know, 18,000
>> from F and C. Okay. But also
from F and C, he's still he's not even including the 28,000 on
his credit card.
So between F and C, if we go back to F and C here,
uh this is F and then C was his his um what do you call it? C
was his total income, right? So F was 23,000. I need this per
month. So $18,000 is like what he is missing according to like
what he's putting forward to the judge is $18,000. But then on
top of that, he also had a $28,000 debt payment.
So this is him saying that I'm actually paying out
$46,000 a month. $46,400 a month. Well, he pays himself 5k >> and
they're just going to go with that
>> They just going to go with the go with the number >> right
here in the morning. Now file on his behalf that he want. So
I think this was filed the day after trial. So you see January
13th right here in the morning. Now, I want you to pay attention
to this because literally almost like 8 hours later, he filed
a second one. He filed a second one. So, let we'll go through
this, right? And then we'll use the second one to calculate uh
the settlement. So, when you go through this, what does he He
wants a divorce. Yes, granted. Done. You're going to get divorce.
Division of community property. He requests the court divide
the community estate in a matter that the court deems justice
right as provided by law. And as set out in exhibit A. >> Oh,
no. if he hold on.
Did Henry add these or Henry must have added these, >> He's
going to get denied or maybe granted in part, but it's not going
to just be 100% granted like, oh, you wanted you you brought
Nick, you did the job for us. You busted down already and you
you're an honest, trustworthy guy, so we're going to divide your
empire the way you see fit because you you're a stand-up guy.
No, it's not happening. It might be granted in part, but probably
denied in part. He also wants to the court to confirm his separate
property. I think that's fair when when we get down to it. Now,
waste and reconstitution. Uh request the court find that Molina
has committed waste on the community property. I don't know what
she did for waste. Not in any of the court docs I saw. I didn't
see it. I'm sure he probably has some great proof of it, but
I didn't see it. He also wants her to pay attorney fees. That's
odd. You like, "Wait, this is a million dollar divorce. You wanted
to pay attorney." Yeah, I wanted her to pay my attorney fees.
Now, when you get down to it, it's about $15,000 extra, I guess,
that he wants her to pay. Request for relief regarding uh motion
to seal the courts. He wants all the documents in his his divorce
to be sealed except for those documents that required by law
to be recorded in the Minnesota court. We as a people have the
right to look at Nick Palom's
divorce proceedings. Not because
we the people, we the people, it's an important right that I
can examine every element of this man's divorce. Okay? It's an
incredibly important thing. I need need need
to be able to examine every single element of this man's divorce.
It's just a harsh requirement. Okay? It's a harsh I need streamer
or become nosy. But to make sure that the judge's decisions are
fair across the board. God forbid you come across a judge who
always awards women 60%. You would need those court filings to
say, "Hey, this judge is biased against men." And every woman
who files for divorce, she automatically awards 60%. No matter
what the circumstances are, 60 60. So this is where these checks
>> I don't agree with people's core. Well, I'm just laughing
at Henry saying it. I do think there are elements that could
remain private. I do think
so. The thing is is it like the reason it's supposed to be public
is so that exactly what Henry's saying, right? That you should
be able to look through the history of the court and see if there
are problems or abuses that need to be addressed. That's why
this stuff's public. That's why it's all public record is because
somebody will need to eventually go through trying to prove some
stuff out, right? Yeah. No worries. human. So that's he's explaining
why it's public record. Now I do think in some cases there there
could be things in here that aren't required for the public record
to prevent abuses and but it's man it gets hard to make those
arguments eventually.
I do agree with you broadly though that like this guy like Nick's
divorce doesn't necessarily need to be entirely public record.
It's also public to encourage settlement. Oh maybe >> analysis
kind of come into play to keep people honest. Nick requested
that all relief by Molina be denied. What does this mean? Lawyer
fees denied. Post spousal maintenance post. >> This seems
extreme. I'm guessing that's why we get another like a refil.
>> Spousal maintenance denied. He wants all that dunzo,
right? Respectfully. And he Now, before we get to this right
here, let's look at the third one. Now, the third one that was
submitted 8 hours later is pretty much the same. There's nothing
uh different other than me pointing out that there is a 400k
discrepancy in his exhibit, which we'll get to. also is is more
of the same, right? I already talked about how the public has
an interest in knowing what the judge is going to do. >> You
probably might see all the account numbers once the case gets
unsealed and you guys can go through my documents cuz I don't
know why in the in God's green earth, you know, uh divorces our
public knowledge. So, you have your opportunity soon enough or
you can watch an illiterate man, you know, who's 85 trying to
go through the documents. If you want to do it that way, too,
it's >> Let's get into Nick. >> Dude, he hates he
hates Henry so much. It's so funny. I don't know why he hates
Henry so much. What did Henry do to you?
The [__] did Henry do to you, dog? >> Pull
spreadsheet
like things to be divided. Now, I want to bring to your attention
that the house in Norway, as you see, has a value of $185,000.
This is how they came to this. I have no idea. Normally, it's
an appraisal of both. Now, what you're going to see is some large
numbers that he has in bank accounts. One account 179,000. 272,000.
some some account 122,000 right here. Now, what he is proposing
is this division, right? So, he's going to say, "Hey, of these
accounts, hey, Molina, remember guys, Molina's on the right,
Nick is on the left. Molina's going to get 179,000. That account
that has that all hers, the account with 272,000, all hers, and
this was the balance of the account as the date that they went
to trial. The Chase account with 122 bucks, he's going to keep.
The Chase account with I believe this had 150,000. He's going
to keep uh 126,000 of it. And she is going to keep 23,000 of
it. Now we keep going down. These are all these are all different.
>> Hold on.
I see nothing here. I see zero in terms Oh, hold on. You have
PayPal, Vinmo, Chase, checking. >> Yes. Brokerage, mutual
fund accounts, publicly traded stocks and numbers, right? This
is the value. This is who's getting what? As we keep going down,
right, you're going to see brokerage accounts in Molina's name.
>> He's saying nothing. He's saying he has no stocks. He's
saying he has nothing.
insane. This guy absolutely has like a money manager. The idea
that he has nothing. The idea that he
has no money, no mutual funds, no brokerage account, no stocks.
He's literally talked about his stocks. Exactly, Slapjack. Yes,
he has literally talked about his stocks and he's going to pretend
that he ain't got no stocks. We talking about here, man.
The is going on here? You ain't got no stocks? Are you kidding
me, dog? You kidding me, dog? >> None. You know why? He
likely had to liquidate it. Likely had to liquidate all his stock
options to pay Molina. And you know, I'm not trying to make fun
of him because look, dude, I've >> No, no, I don't think
they do that. Especially Especially when they're RSUs. They don't
do that. Um I think Henry's just wrong here. And maybe he just
didn't have RSUs involved in his divorce, but I don't think so.
I had a buddy get divorced who was like a big executive at one
of the tech companies I worked at and from what I understand
uh he had to open a brokerage account for the other person and
then just split the stock,
right?
Like that's just wrong. You don't have to liquidate the stock.
You you have to open a brokerage account and split the RSUs
and then they just have the same vesting schedule and everything.
That's that's how that works. >> I know the pain of closing
an account and taking proceeds and busting that joint down straight
to your ex-wife. It's not fun. I wish no man but this is where
we are. So that's why you see this. So all that Nvidia stock
that millions I guess was sold or or or
now let's just hope Nick is not hiding assets and playing the
high asset game because that could only be to his detriment if
it ever gets found out. >> A huge mistake.
>> He bought gold in and cash and it gold in cash and is
burying it in his yard. >> Make is messing around with
the money in a divorce. You may think, hey, I earn this money.
This is my money. I can do with it whatever I want. The thing
is in Texas, we have community property. If you earned it during
the marriage, it's both of y'alls. You're going to your own self
in the foot. If you start hiding that money, putting it where
she can't get it, leave her where she can't pay bills or buy
the kids school clothes, you will eat those actions as such a
bitter pill in the divorce process. And it's going to cost you
more money cuz eventually she's going to get access to the money
cuz it's half hers. So, let's not do that. Let's let cooler heads
prevail and and be on the up and up about the money. It will
benefit you and get you more money in the long run. Going back
to his trust >> I that's continue to go down the NMP low
productions. This is interesting, right? Has it at a worth $65,000?
F. And he's saying, look, this was the average valuation by his
people and her people. Now, who knows what her people value at.
I wish he would have submitted a spreadsheet, but maybe she didn't
want to overstep because she knew Nick was. And guys, >> that's
interesting. He says 100%.
>> Now, hold on. Wait. 100%. We'll see where it comes out
in the end. I think this is basically the the total outcome of
this. The thing that Nick proposes is like a 50-50 split. >> Nick
in my divorce and I would 100% submitted a spreadsheet and we
we settled ours out of court. So the escalade now this where
the >> No, this is just this is his business that probably
all of his income comes >> Gets interesting, right? Because
if I'm not mistaken,
this is the third
this is the third submitt that he did, right? This is the third.
Now look, we we're going to figure this out real quick, right?
So look, we have this third. Let's go to the top. Make sure.
>> Yeah, submitt. >> This is the third one. This
is the one submitted at 8 submitt. >> Now, you have to
ask yourself on the original one that was submitted at uh 8
>> Why did he have it at
120,000
earlier in the day, but then later in the day had it at
100,000. We got to go back to the third one because once he submits
this new one, the other one is kind of like null and void. So,
as we go back down to the third one, you will see the $65,000
valuation and the $100,000
valuation for the card. Now, here's the here's the thing to think
about when it comes to Nick Polo Productions LLC. Who is the
judge going to believe? Is the judge going to take the average
of the two and say, "Okay, $65,000." Or will the judge just take
Nicks, which could be lower, or Melanus? Typically, the judge
is going to take the evaluation of the two and split it down
the middle. That's the fair thing to do. Now, as far as the Cadillac
getting sunseted, yeah, it looks like, is she requesting it or
is he selling it? That's gonna be a great question. But here
is where the $450,000
mistake comes into play, right? Let's zoom out. So, you have
this Chase banking account. XX
X. There's no net value. The net value of the Chase banking account,
there's nothing there. Same with this one. It's just a X. Just
a X. I was just like, "Look, why do you have a value for pretty
much everything else and just a X for these accounts?" >> I'm
assuming these are closed accounts that they closed those accounts.
Oh, is this going to tell us that because they closed these accounts?
I'm guessing that's what it is. Okay, we closed these accounts.
We checked them. We We checked out all the money, right?
And we're going to put they're putting it in here, but because
they closed them, does that indicate that he's moving to a different
holding company for his business? In my mind, these accounts
should be considered part of the divorce. They're not listed
as separate property. So, he's >> Oh, wait. No. I'm guessing
that these accounts are a part of the evaluation for NMP Productions,
right? Closely held business interests like Chase Business Checking.
These are probably for the NMP Law Productions LLC, both of these.
So, they'd be included in this amount here. Oh, is Henry missing
that? I think there's basically 150,000 in value in this company,
they're saying, and then 450,000 in these accounts. That seems
pretty clear. >> These accounts should be considered part
of the divorce. >> See what Henry has to say. They're not
listed as separate property. So, he's basically saying, look,
this 300 this
>> Yeah, this going to be to me because remember, he he
he's on the left, she's on the right. He wants that money for
him, but not a part of the settlement, which is very odd. I'm
just like, "Wait, what?" And they imagine this, right? Imagine
doing this, going through it twice, resubmitting, and still just
putting like, "Hey, we don't we don't got no value for that."
But you know the balance. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. We know the balance.
But this going to come to me. It's going to come to me, judge.
Come on, judge. Wait. Wait. What? Why is this not part of the
calculation? You know, a piece of me wants him to be granted
the ability to speak cuz maybe he'll start reacting and just
say, "I'm lying because he he must assume I I know. >> I
Man, am I am I crazy or did Henry just misread this?" like he
doesn't >> know some extra information that, you know,
I'm just not reporting on, but I would love for him to explain
it. I would love it. I would truly welcome the opportunity. So,
as we keep going down right now, when it comes to OTK Media,
there go right there. $480,000 class B stocks. Now, I know this
balance of $1,000 is not negative to Nick for the credit card,
but I really want to talk about the but the shares, the OTK,
Inc., the class B common stock shares. He proposes that he transfer
50% of the shares in OTK to Molina. Is that fair? Is that what
she wants? And him to be the constructive trustee for Molina's
50% share until the transfer is completed. Now, I think that's
that's going to happen because this everything surrounding OTK
been very very sketchy for in court docs. Like I don't know if
she knows if who owns what, who the owners are. Whereas Misfit
play into this whole thing or not. Don't know. Now, as far as
King Forge or King Gaming Labs, which is Star Forge system, counts
roughly 93,000
and all shares to be sold, proceeds, net of taxes to be divided
between the parties. What if she doesn't want to sell sell her
shares of King Gaming Labs? What if she wants to keep them? You
see how like decisions are he's recommending this decision? Was
she on a board with it? Because what they could have agreed to
was a partial settlement like, "Hey, judge, we agree on this,
this, this, and this, and not that, that that, that, and that."
Well, it looks like there was no partial settlement entered.
They don't agree on anything for from what it looks like. So,
as you keep going down, retire benefits, none in either's name.
Uh, health savings account, none. He likely had to liquidate
them if he had them. If he had them. Keep going down.
I Yeah, I just think I think this is all indic indicative of,
in my opinion, if Nick liquidated, I think that would be a horrible
I don't even know. I think your lawyers would tell you not to
liquidate, right? If you're holding stock, I do believe your
lawyers would say, "No, no, no. Don't liquidate that because
all you're going to do is create problems if you liquidate it
now after the divorce has started, right? You go to liquidate
those shares.
What might happen is if those shares like skyrocket for some
reason,
what happens if if for some reason those shares skyrocket like
those like you have uh some stocks or something, Henry thinks
they're liquidated. If they go up right in value after the fact,
she's going to say, "Why did you liquidate them? I wanted those."
Right? I I do believe a lawyer would tell you don't liquidate
it. You're just going to create problems for yourself, right?
You might create an issue where you have to actually like give
her the difference in value as well.
Yeah. Yeah. I I do believe this would be the case. I don't know
for sure, Charging Jim, but I think basically making major decisions
about your financials that could like alter significantly the
outcome of your divorce. I think lawyers are always going to
tell you no, you're frozen on like a lot of your assets right
now. Like don't make big decisions or try to clear it. Like we
could try to clear it through the other party. If you want to
liquidate this stuff, you could try to clear it through the other
party. We could try that. But you can't make major decisions,
right? Unless there's some real compelling reason you have to
like the stocks crashing or I don't know, there's a conflict.
I don't know exactly what would be a compelling reason in this
case. But
>> he's he's >> Yeah, but lawyers aren't really on
your side. No, they're absolutely on your side. Pro five. Lawyers
are on your side. They just are going to take your a lawyer will
tell you that here's here's how a lawyer's on your side.
I truly believe this at this point, okay, that lawyers are essentially
never against you, but people get that impression because they
get egotistical first and don't let the lawyer tell them what
to do. Every lawyer is going to tell you, every lawyer can like
ballpark in my opinion what like a settlement would be in some
civil action that they're covering, right? They'll they'll basically
say this to you. They'll be like, "Okay, you should settle this,
and you're not going to like it, but here's the reality of like
what it'll come out to, and so you should settle." And it's going
to feel bitter. It's going to be a bitter pill for you to swallow.
That the idea that you should take like this low amount of money
or that the idea that you should take the low amount of money
or you should be giving away a lot of money, it's going to feel
like bitter, and you're going to go, "No, I I want to fight this.
It's wrong." But the lawyer is just telling you, "This is what
you should do. This is I I I cover this all the time. I do like,
right? I do these cases all the time. Here's what you should
do. Don't be stupid. You're only going to hurt yourself. Don't
be stupid.
And I think basically everybody gets emotional when they decide
to be >> request he keeps the GTR and he has it valued
at $100,000. Is it valued more? Who knows? Household furnishings.
Obviously, they're going to keep their own. But let's get down
to the to the real stuff. The Pokemon card collection, the Magic
the Gathering card collection. What's going to happen to that?
Now E's hoping that the parties to divide in time 50/50. Hey,
let's just go through the cards 50/50. I'm not sure how that
works. What if she doesn't want to keep the cards? This is where
it gets murky. Like we got cards.
>> I feel like in this case, you take them to an appraiser,
you get them appraised, and you take the value, and if you want
them, you just pay out, right? I that that to me says actually
there's just way too much money in cards here
that he doesn't want to get it appraised because it'll be like
a tangible asset he'll have to pay more money out for. >> Now
the judge can be like, "You know what? Let's come back. Come
back and y'all pick out what cards you want." I doubt that'll
happen. Probably be auctioned off and y'all split the proceeds.
Uh club memberships, none. Or they keep they keep the clubs in
their name. They keep those. Uh safety deposit boxes, none.
Jesus Christ. Hey, that's where the money at, right? I don't
got no safety deposit box. Okay. Uh he's recommending that they
keep their own social media accounts. Uh this was another thing
that I thought was sketchy as like look, he wants people to believe.
this is a big one, isn't it?
I think I saw Nick talking while he was discussing like he had
a Counter-Strike inventory there.
How much you got in How much you got in skins? How much you got
in knives, bro? How much you got in knives? This is This is an
X as in I just get to keep all of it and I don't have it, you
know, valued. But how much is he keeping in knives right now?
I I know any streamer who's going to go through like some Counter-Strike
inventory on stream. I do feel I think it was Counter-Strike.
Maybe it could have been Rust or something. Maybe I just didn't
recognize the game >> that he only has $20,000
$22,000 in
>> You got me. I don't know about that, man. I don't know
about that. Interesting. Interesting. Wait, come on, guys. Do
you really think Nick only has $22,000
in cryptocurrency? As long as cryptocurrency has been around,
friends with XQC. Now, here's the thing. Some people will argue
that putting your money in cryptocurrency can you can hide
>> New court docs obtained. Part two coming soon. Let's
go. >> I'm not saying he's doing that, but Jesus Christ,
man. 22,000 maybe. Now, we keep going down the list. I guess
he has a Chase Sapphire card with $27,000 which he's going to
eat and the lawyer fees of which he owes he's going to eat as
well. Now what gets
I guess you know she has her lawyer fees of $15,000.
How do you want to calculate for that? Who knows? But what gets
petty to me is not this. It's the fact that this is what he's
offering her, right? So, he's offering her a
>> I think this $440,000
error is very likely
I think it's very likely
included as a part of the valuation of the company. So, maybe
maybe it's an error and it wasn't included in the valuation of
the company. They said they'd put it on these documents after
the fact, but I'm guessing it's in the $65,000
valuation of NMP LLC, NMP Gaming LLC or whatever. And I don't
think it's actually an error in his favor. I would want to see
what this $43,000 in waste was. That would be >> Settlement
of $830,000
right here. This is what he's offering. But there is a $440,000
error in his favor, which brings him walking away with $1.2 million
and her walking away with $830,000.
If y'all think that's fair, who knows? Also, he's accusing her
of wasting $43,000 wasted community funds. I'm not sure what
she wasted funds on, but there goes the settlement. Now, what
gets petty, right, is this in the end. He wants her, he's requesting
for attorney fees from her, right? $15,000 to be paid to. Now,
you have to think about this. Think long
>> I don't care about that. >> I don't care about
that. I want whatever this is, okay? >> Separate property
of Nicholas. YouTube accounts, Twitch accounts, Instagram accounts,
Facebook accounts.
Now, you could think of it purely this way, right? But these
aren't these aren't assets of Nicholas purely, and I think judging
them as such would be stupid. They they have to be when all of
the revenue of
the business
comes via these accounts.
In my opinion, you have to consider them a part of the business.
They're like assets of the business,
man. Although, listen, I do think it's pretty clear though. I
I think a lot of states have basically anything you have from
before the divorce can still be yours, right? Could be considered
outside the scope. But I do wonder how that works when it's like
you start a business and then you marry somebody and then you
both build that business together, but you started it on your
own. I don't see how that could possibly be the case. Oh, well,
I, you know, registered this LLC when we weren't together and
now we build this business.
Wouldn't crypto be a perfect place to hide money? No.
Crypto is people think crypto is a good way to hide money. It's
not. Crypto creates a paper trail. There are ways through crypto
by which you can offiscate your money, but basically like
essentially what you crypto there's a perfect paper trail of
where all your money is going that is immutable. Okay, there
are ways you can offiscate your money, but then it's basically
like, well, here's all my money and I'm sending it around and
then I threw it in a big black hole. Don't ask me what happened
after that black hole, right? People are referring to Monero.
That is a privacy coin. There are a lot of privacy coins, right?
There are cryptos where you can hide the amount of money you're
sending. That does exist, right? Um there are cryptos where you
can like scramble them totally and launder your money, but eventually
they're going to see all of your money going into something and
disappearing,
right? And what do you do? You go like, I was scammed. Well,
I don't know if you can do that. That's probably what you got
to do, right? You probably got to fake getting your wallet hacked
and let all the crypto get drained out into like a brokerage
account. Not a brokerage account, but like a a
centralized exchange, okay? Like Binance or something. And then
it would get sold out there. You'd go into something to do like
some some Tumblr thing. You do um the [__] is it?
Tornado cash. You do something like tornado cash. Cash that all
out. Put basically once that's on then now that is private. That's
no longer known to anybody. Then you take that money, you put
it into like another brokerage account that you register through
some other accounts that you don't have linked to anything. And
then eventually you could maybe withdraw that later, way later
after you're through this divorce, like 10 years from now, 15
years from now, you could do something like that, but my god,
if you get caught doing that and it just disappears and you don't
really have a good excuse for like how that money got stolen
from you, that's that's going to go bad for you, man. who is
literally making
roughly
Right? So, your judge that's looking over this is making $175,000
and you have this guy who was about to who has more than this
judge's salary in a bank account sitting doing nothing going
to decide if his soon to be ex-wife should pay him back $15,000
of his attorney fees. I think this is going to get All right,
Dude, do we have somewhere the um the Nvidia stock? Nvidia stock
NMP. LOL. Hold on. I have to I have to see if I can find that
Nvidia clip and when it's from cuz my goodness,
this guy is like a this guy's like a dumb dude. But I'm almost
positive. Yeah, two years ago. >> How do you do with the
stock market? >> Oh, fantastic.
>> but you know, you want to know why I do fantastic? It's
cuz I literally just invest in the S&P 500 and I just walk
>> You know what's crazy?
>> I put 750K in into Nvidia. >> So that's
way more than we thought. That is in 2023.
So 2023. We go to NVDA price.
We want the 5year on NVDA. It's in 2023. This clip is June 27th,
2023. June 27th, 2023. the price is $40. Okay, that's after this.
That's I think these are all changed for like the split, right?
If if he goes if you go back far enough, if you go back into
2022, like when he bought it, right? Maybe he'll say, but even
if it was here, even if it was right after this this bump up,
30 bucks, we'll say that's still a 6x on 750K.
So 6 times
750 if it was to the modern to to the current day. Uh sorry,
six
I'm 750.
So, he's going to be talking about it down here at like $27,
like $30, $27. Yeah, it's possible he just lied. And it's possible
he sold it up here when it was worth a lot, you know?
Oh, wait though. Hold on. Wait though. Wait though. Wait though.
I'm up, right? Cuz this would have been before the stock split.
When was the um when was the Nvidia stock split?
Uh there was one in June 2024.
most recent being a 10 to1 stock split. So when he says he put
that in, it's not actually $30, right? Is it? Oh, no. No. I'm
I'm thinking this wrong because this this would be the price.
This is I think it it backdates the stock split. Never mind.
Never mind. Never mind. Never mind. Never mind. Wait. No. Cuz
cuz it wouldn't be 30 bucks. No, it would be No, no, it would
be. Dude, there's no way that he put the equivalent of 7.5 million
in, right? There's no way that he put the equivalent of 7.5 million
into Nvidia in 2022. That's not possible. There's no way. There's
no way. There's no way. There's no way. There's no way. And by
the way, it's also very likely if he's somebody who will just
drop 7. By the way, hold on. There's another whole thing here.
Did this really just say that he dropped half of his total net
worth on Nvidia stock alone? Did this guy really just say that
he dropped half of his net worth on video Nvidia stock? I only
have $1.5 million in net worth. 1.6 million. And I dropped 750K
in Nvidia. this guy. There's no way.
Also, guys, we're uh we're ending the Twitch stream. So, head
over to kkick.com/jalkk.
We're going to continue covering this. See you there in a little
bit. Bye. Just I don't think the soft eight counts, but if it
does, I don't want that to go through. So, we're going to go
and delete that VOD.
I don't think it counts. I just don't want to risk it. Like,
it it can't count cuz I've literally never had a problem before.
But just in case, they decided in this one case they're going
to try to count it. That VOD goes away. That VOD don't exist
anymore. No, they've never counted it before, like the soft A.
But I don't even want to risk it. I don't want to risk it. That
feels like crazy. No, no, thank you. Okay, we shut the Twitch
stream off.
Twitch stream gone. He's gone. He's gone. He's gone.
All
Holy. Okay. Anyway, dude, that because then Yeah, the price would
have been cheaper back here. He's saying he would have bought
it like three bucks,
right? Dude, there's no way. I'm just There's no possible way.
Yeah. Keep listening. >> Wait, so you're chilling? >> Maybe
as [__] now. >> Wait, that's You're rich as
[__] now. >> Rich as
>> Wait, when did you put it? >> Literally like four
or five years ago.
He just has to be lying, I guess.
Um, yeah, he has to be lying. Four or five years ago from That's
2019.
That's uh 2019.
That's like six bucks on the current thing.
Yeah.
There's just no possible way. Uh maybe he'll say that he sold
it.
>> Rich as >> Oh my god. >> It's crazy. >> You
750k 5 years ago. >> All the money that I had up until
that moment. Yeah. Just throw it in that >> Isn't that
like 5 mil? >> I don't want to say, but it's a lot. Someone
says, "Yet you drive a GTR."
he's got to be lying there, right?
He's got to be He's got to be lying. He said, "All the money
I made up to that point, 750k up to that point, he put it in
Nvidia." There's just no way. I don't believe that that would
have happened.
Like that story is just totally unbelievable anyway, right?
That story is just completely unbelievable. If that story were
true and he'd kept it till today, he would be Molina would be
getting like a eight figure settlement at minimum. Seems like
he was exaggerating, not fully lying. We'll see
he's lying then or Well, I mean, he's lying now. He's just almost
certainly lying now. But I guess he'll just say that I was lying
back then.
>> I don't think the judge is going to do >> Also,
going forward, he wants to keep his YouTube Twitch accounts,
which I looked into, they were acquired before marriage. So,
I see no issue in that. I don't see no issue in that. And that
is their whole divorce settlement. Now, how this is going to
play out, I have no idea. Will the judge grant him what he wants?
Probably not. Probably not. Not completely. Not with this $440,000
error. Will he resubmit with new information? Maybe. But that's
God knows. Now, in closing, right, if you want to see the whole
spreadsheets, I'll post them at the end of this. But I I did
want to say a couple things in closing regarding this. I'm sure
Nick is watching right now and he experiencing all sorts of emotion,
but I want to go back to your comment about me having a daughter
and I should be embarrassed. My daughter gives me something that
you have yet to experience. She brings me pure happiness. She's
5 years old and can care less about my viewership. Remember,
this is a hobby of mine. Okay. Not a great look from Henry to
cope over this. Just literally, but it's not cope. It's almost
certainly the truth. It's just that Nick doesn't care what the
truth is. He's just saying that because he's like mad at you,
right? Nick doesn't give a [__] about what the truth
>> despite you being worth over millions and having access
to way more views than I would ever have going live. At the end
of the day, I am going to go back to my 9 to5. But I would take
my 9 to5 and my daughter's love every time over being some pathetic
miserable millionaire who spends his free time checking X and
LSF and 4chan for what people are saying about him that's most
likely true. Then spend time trying to figure out how I can remove
that from online. Your whole purpose right now is monitoring
your online reputation, worrying about viewership. You're right.
If I were to switch places with you, I probably would end myself
because there's so much more to life than what people are saying
about you on the internet, especially people that you have never
met before in your life. But if you're truly going to yourself,
do me one simple favor, right? Do me one favor if you're going
to do it right. Don't announce it. Just bounce. >> Okay,
the last bit is funny. I unfortunately think that this whole
accounting error he was pointing out. I think that's wrong. But
that Vraane was talking about Henry. The last part was um that
did go a little bit hard actually. I thought I thought it was
like a little much. The last part was pretty funny though. Don't
let us know. That's like Darius was gambling at some point or
freaking out on stream back before I streamed. And I'll get him
on kick. I just I told him I was like Darius, you need to go
figure out how to get like a pistol. Okay. Because like when
you're in this moment the next time, the next time this moment
approaches, I don't want you to have time to reconsider.
Okay? I know we need to take advantage of that in the- moment
emotion. Okay? That outpouring of emotion. I don't want you to
have time to reconsider anything. I want you to have the means
right next to you. It was over It was over one of those things
where he was looping on something. Okay? It made sense at the
time. It was mean, but it made sense at the time.
All right.
Now, I think we had an XQC reaction to at least the numbers,
if nothing else.
>> forgot about this >> 60 yo yo chat I would have
only dark >> here hold on hold on hold on
60 yo yo chat I would have only dark thoughts if that was looming
over arguments of why I think she has a great shot at getting
60% reason being she could prove waste she could prove by the
letter of the law that he cheated it's no shock that the going
forward what what is her stream of >> I think people are
being unfair to Nick uh it's very shortsighted like if you to
really get down to the business and really think about and strategize
and see okay or analyze what is the total contribution or whatever
it it it's not like that you get 50% it's what they signed for
yeah oh I just had a realization I just had a sudden realization
it should say somewhere in these documents do we know the date
the start date of their marriage cuz if NMP is saying four or
five years ago I bought it. That makes it like that means it's
like 2019 2020
then he might not have been married yet. They might not not have
actually gotten married yet in 2019.
Hold on. Let me see if I can put that into like Perplexity if
it knows. Give me a second. Did uh when did NMP Lol and Molina
Molina get married?
Could Could Perplexity tell me this? Oh, September 2015.
I know it would have been in these documents somewhere. That's
brutal. Never mind. Never mind. That is Yeah, cuz he You're right.
He made the She just made the 10-year thing. True, true, true,
true,
>> true. I get all those all those thoughts. Whatever.
But when it really comes down to it, guys,
>> NMP's stream and from from the beginning to the end,
>> all of XQC's opinions on this are from the position
of a battered woman. Okay? He was battered by Adept. Adept did
not have the same thing and he all of his positions on this will
be total like traum traumatic um maladaptations from his experience
with adept. You can take XQC serious on none of these things.
It's all going to be him seeing Adept every time he ever talks
about this topic. He has no clue what he's talking about. It's
all going to be him being like, "Well, Adept tried to clean me
out and that was really wrong." And so this is wrong here, too.
>> And it's a lot of effort. And a lot of efforts are at
the beginning when you have no viewers. A lot of effort is when
you're not making money. a lot of building this that career is
whenever nobody is there and yeah I get but it's all the early
game and the mid game stuff and yeah I get issues around and
more more late game or whatever and and but but dude
I 85 90%
I would love to talk to XC about this I would love to that would
be very funny to talk to XCC about this he would never do it
ever but it would be awesome to do cuz I think he's coping here
entire And if he watched this entire video, that's I got to go
find his reaction. Actually, we we actually have to go to the
XQC reaction cuz what did he say when he sees Nick's assets?
When he sees the total asset split there, when he sees like the
total assets for Nick, what does he say?
There's no possible way he could just accept that. Like, oh,
actually that total asset split that makes total sense. Yeah,
Nick Nick only has $1.6 million. Yeah, I bet that's true. There's
no way, right? Oh, was he just reacting to like
tweets and Oh, god damn it. He wasn't reacting to anything serious.
>> Here it is. Here it is. Here it is.
>> Requesting a permanent. >> There it is.
>> Now, is he going to watch the whole
>> No, actually, actually, >> I feel like he's going
to quit out before Yeah. >> He's not going to come close
to making it, is he? Oh, here we go. No. Bring that. Is this
Is this um Yeah. >> Oh [__]
>> Yes. This is close.
>> The [__] is that? Whoa. Whoa. Whoa.
That's That's pre-filed. I'm not going to lie. That's pretty
file. That's a That's a pretty crazy
data on there. No.
>> No. I mean, that's a What did he think divorces were?
THAT'S REALLY CRAZY DATA ON THERE, GUYS. WAIT, what do you mean?
Wait, what do you mean?
>> That's pretty crazy data. What What the does that even
mean? >> That is too crazy for me. >> And annoying
and and just cringe. >> I just want SEC's reaction to seeing
that NMP's entire business, everything he earned for the past
10 years is worth $1.6 million. Do you think that's true? Yes
or no? Yes or no? Is that true? You tell me, Nick.
or XQC, whoever, whoever wants to answer that question, cuz I
think that's that's an absurd thing to throw